Stanford and you talk about MVPs with
fixed discount factors okay thanks to
the organizers asked me to give a talk
over there it's my first time to Simmons
so I'm going to talk about Markov
decision process with fixed it is can't
hear i'm not talking about something new
some is pretty old stuff and the show is
to policy iteration method and and
together with the simplex method ok so
I'm associated with department of
management of science and also
computational i cme ok so here's my
outline so I'm talk about a linear
programming so that's a big pictures and
which is under nine mark of decision
process then I'm going to give a very
quick introduction with the back of
decision process and also what's the
macro full process game then I summarize
couple for advances in simplex at the
policy division method in the past maybe
five years then i'm going to give some
remarks and open problems ok so first
linear programming there's a big
pictures you know a ninny programming to
me is remain one of the core
computational problems in the current
century the past century as well and so
developed by couple for Giants and
equipment control over G and the middle
is George Danzig that's the simplex
method okay so amazingly and linear
programming still very very widely used
today and many many people use them to
solve practical problems and also even
use linear program prove theorems level
some kind of under nine use some lower
bond duality theories okay lineage or
has very simple algebraic form okay so
you basically have X is called decision
variables you give matrix a which is M
by n okay which is given let's count as
a data you're also given right hand side
B that's also part of the data and then
you want to decide ex and the X has to
be non active so you want to minimize
this objective function which is given
and objective factors okay again this is
a standard help you form vaguely is a n
dimensional vector need to be optimally
decided so in some sense LP is a typical
data driven computational decision model
and that you give an ABC then your
output eggs so that's the you know in
the today a getting bigger and bigger
and am ben is also going vehicle so
people still constantly sochi is the
better algorithm to solve linear
programming algorithm okay from
geometric point of view and the nene
program actually is a polygon and this
is kinda as a feasible region you want
finding optimal vortex which is to have
the highest or most favorable objective
values so the question is how should i
search along these polygons and to reach
that pre- level which is our target so
to Agrium's which is of even up today
and also many many efforts has been made
to me and other commercial or public
domain software is implement either the
simplex method which is Georgie density
invented almost 70 years ago by moving
from vertex to vertex okay and then
somehow and he can prove and you can
reach the optimal vertex
in so-called finite time number steps
another method which is studied in
master century 80s which is in two point
method which go through the interior
feasible region and reach the optimal
vortex so although we have lot of first
order or some other method that come out
and so far cyano and this is to know
working horses and in this field ok so
those new things has not been mature
enough to be implemented by any
commercial software ok ok so this 2
method but it's the Tweety two different
stories the simplex method all the
theoretical result are somehow very
inactive whenever you develop a simplex
method then people construct the context
ampoules in the worst case that pivot in
rule or simplex method has to be
exponentially in number of steps ok for
another hand into Buena method is all
good news lean on even today we still
have people in a mighty got one America
center you can try to improve it ok but
some of those poverty is not really
implementable but still tried
traditional classical interval measure
as we implemented so there was a kind of
a disconnect with in and the spatula for
simplex method and disconnect from
theory and practical performance so
today I'm just try to to be positive and
bring cup of good news for simplex
method ok ok so this comes out to solve
Markov decision process and again ok I
know poverty many people here popular
you heard about a Markov decision
process so I'm going to be very quickly
review ok even with some toy examples so
mdp provides a mathematical framework
modern in sequential decision-making
situation so I'll come apart around
done partly under control decision maker
that's the theme of this workshop and
uncertainty useful study dynamic
programming actually many many problems
can be especially in the name of dynamic
programming and so can be formulated and
that goes very old days okay it was many
many modern applications especially in
the landing heard about a lot of talk
today somehow which fit into this kind
of framework okay at each time step the
process is income state I so in this
talk I'm going to say there with em
States okay and the decision to make
choose action in some sad okay that is
the AI a sub a is means the action
available for state I so you can sink a
state is the agent you can play any any
action or play you can okay I chosen at
the middle corresponding cost fgh then
the process response next time by
randomly moving into a new state okay I
called I prime then the prophets and the
choose X so this probability which is
not for sure but which state are going
to be in the next time is dependent on
this probability okay specifically is
given by state transition distribution
probability p g which is empty um m
state to moving okay but given as action
Jay and the probability is independent
so that's why we call the mark of
decision process okay so what's the M
deeper problems the turnout for
stationary this kind of a Markov
decision process if you place this
process long enough you actually funding
the with a stationary policy which means
each state each agent always play that
the same action nor ever that's the
optimum or you can think about each one
have many many cards to play
oh you have a winning card optimal card
to play with so the questions how to
find that winning card for each state
which is PI 12 / m and number stays okay
so over words choose ok so I'm DB again
to find so usually because this is the
infinite horizon programs we usually
associated with the discount factor
which means the future value is the
comdata prepped precentor values so this
is a pretty standard assume and we have
to assume future is the count as today
okay another hand this is the mark of
decision process if the state's actually
a partition into two sets one actually
is trying to minimize another sad is
trying to maximize then at the process
become what we so called two percent 10
base 20 some stochastic game so that's
typically people formulate this play
game and typically with these kind of
things so you have you pray card and you
have one want to minimize on to minimize
ok so this is called a stochastic game
typically discount factor gamma which is
1 plus Rowland's it's basically interest
rate staff so that's the standard okay
so this is a toy examples okay I have a
0 1 2 3 in labeled as a state this is a
this is the toy this is quarters
absorbing state okay all these edges can
be represented as this flow as a graph
okay as edges so acting for this state
they can take red actions or take a blue
actions if you take a red actions for
sure you're going to move into state one
if you take blue actions then fifty
percent you move here 25 months ago here
one is move over there and also one is
involved it so that's that's what it
part okay so you can
that immediate a cost action cost kind
of so she s edgecast for these problems
so I'm going to have a 0-0 every action
have a zero you mediate a cost but
however there was a cost which is at a
state of fourth of a slow choice you
have to pray this action then you're
paying 1 million dollars whatever so
that's okay the question is what is the
optimal policy for these agents for all
the agents if they want to play this
game level and you can see the optimus
l3 optimal policy would it be red red
red blue and reach this observe you
state with no cost is that clear okay so
that's the optimal policy okay so you
can think about this repeat again again
but this is a toy example actually one
time optimal strategy would be also
optimal for invalid horizon anyway
whatever the questions how can we find
is that a policy red red red blue yep so
this is a sink okay I just simplify this
little bit and they instead up for two
too many edges over there I just say you
have a 50-percent here fifty percent of
here then fifty percent of year 59 so
just a simplified graph looks like a
little bit cleaner okay but it's the
same thing well it turned out funding
such a optimal policy or finding optimal
solution for that problem can be
formulated as a linear program problems
okay so this is all the gear here are
all the actions associated with the
first agent so you just need to finding
y1 which is a value for that a state
which is not equal to c g plus gamma as
our discount which is PG at times y okay
this is true for each state and you just
maximize the sum of all the way I we
turn out and this is a linear
programming formulation for infinite
horizon and mdp problems
so you will solve that inappropriate
problems you can find it okay so this is
a problems okay in some way this is
usually in the linear programming
language we call this isn't like a do
stand on a fool okay so this is a heavy
inequalities and you maximize and
everything ok so it's the two phone
here's the interpretation popular many
people know why actually represent
expertly presenta cost to go value of M
states that if you lend the MDP from
other language and that's what it is
okay it's just a actually the finding
optimal cost to go values ok that's the
Nene program moment so actually chosen
why there was another interpretation
your max why actually is try to find a
fixed point such that y star equal to
means each year plus lambda pget I
should have a waste I over here as well
so this is actually fixed point so you
have this wire on the both side okay
then the optimal action is just a arca
meaning of that scenes but again this
should be 0 x star and just lucky okay
so it's fun to find mix okay in the game
as a fixed point is for some state you
have been for some you have a max so
that's again still fix for it ok so
that's the difference between this I'm
going to talk about what's the recent
advances on both so of Markov decision
process uniform beam or you actually
have some people want mean another one
max
so here's the cost of the goal value
okay for example is really keeping on
your policy suppose you take a red red
red red actions if you take a red action
what's the cost to go value for state
number four for sure you have no choice
you have to pay my million dollars okay
then since this guy enter this guy so 1
million dollars if you have a discount
point a nine then that's nine hundred
thousand dollars you can do this okay
yeah I'm soon don't discount so that's
what the cost of go values to this okay
well is this value a fixed point no this
is not a fixed point because at this one
is not equal to being of these two
because you go here is the zeros okay
and is that the fixed point for this
estate know if you go here is one but
you go there and you have a pop for
centre-half person or grill actually is
only half so this is not the optimal
partisan same time it's not the fixed
point well here's the primal LP form of
the MDP once you have a do you have a
primal so you can write this as and
minimize some of next year overall the
actions here assume the action all and
actions partitioned into em given the
group okay some for for example 125
photo first state or 64 10 for the
second status or you can just read this
Yeji is one when Jesus well it's easier
to write okay the primer variable
represent expected action flow of
frequency that is the expert the preset
value of a lump of x action gia is being
chosen okay so this is a or you can fend
you can think about this is more like a
generalize the network flow discontent
then when you can also actually have a
different ages come factor for different
action so if all the gamma has the same
garment is can't we say md beer has
unifor
otherwise we say have a non-uniform
discount factor non-uniformities kind of
factors more similar to long as
generalized network flow so generalized
flow means when you flow in flow out be
different has some kind of a discount or
leakage so here's couple for algorithmic
events of the MTP okay sharply and the
belmont developments called a value
iteration because this is a fixed point
operations so it just continued operate
you know it's like you can prove as long
as you have a and discount and map is
contractions and you can do it okay but
that's a continuous iterative process
another personal mastery studio on
Howard okay in 1960s our colleague and
and it's not and supports the iteration
method which is generated a warped
imbecile in finite number of revision
you somehow a very disputed and it is
centralized the way so you have a policy
you compare the cost to the go values
okay then you broadcast this naked
massagee parts into all the state states
cuz these state of values then the
fandom what's the best response okay
very tournament very decentralized so
that's the process so that's why people
like this process because they can be
implement in very very distributed
decentralized away also yes the
computation of the cast ago seems to
require yes yes but however you need to
have a centralized the guy take an
action then somehow centralized the
convert so people usually update it you
know it's like a matrix inversion that's
right it is that's right and but a value
iteration is much much cheaper that's
right yes correct okay but in terms of
finding optimal policy poverty and have
some kind of matrix or avenging order
yet you need some more or they
well the simplex another hand because
you can formulate as a simplex method so
simple acts message can also help to
solve okay so is somehow and and there
is also give very popular so you updated
one at a time so as I said and the
simplex method into point of us are very
alive form mdp but however for MDB I my
own mythology is most people just use
the policy two regimes because so this
is still fast because India important
even leave the universe or even big
matrix so so this is what people you
really use okay so so yes you have to do
the cost of go values okay again this is
the cost to go value so what's the
policy iteration method partisan regions
once we understand it cost to go value
then we can evaluate expected the cost
of each actions then each state move to
the cheapest one tuna the mean one so in
this case and this one go here is one
code here is de lo this one go here is
one cuz this is the half this one goes
this is one cuz this is a super force
this one go here is this 7 force so our
parts of the region just move here I'm
just assume read actions are actually
chosen forever yeah and you have a new
that's just like a rather sad you have
to buy the Sally you have to computer
than usual and computer that could be
very demanding but but people can use
some other method its rating method to
solve you know yeah so okay so this is a
this one another is the simplex what's
the simplex method simplex method
actually is changing one switch one
state at a time whatever so that's what
what it is about ok and so you have
example previous one this one there was
a index rule everybody
no you always switch because in the
simplex must have many many way to
improve which variable you you pick
enter the basis you always this mostly
index so in this case you took a small
values and switch over there ok another
hand the original George tentacle Ruiz
which status which action we created the
largest an improvement that that's what
you've been through so for George dance
group they were switching from one two
zeros so once you do that what's the new
customer value then you have 1000 in
this case it turned out it is optimal
okay so it turned out people already
find for even for this toy example you
humans the smooth index rule if you
follow this kind of rule it turned out
even for this small problem you need to
to the power 5 steps to convert ok
because of whenever you switch next time
you switch aziz once you switch these
you switch this back ok it's just
alternating alternating alternating so
this is a very cute example to show if
you follows most index roof or mdp
actually you your exponential number
steps ok this is a story ok so now
basically however for this program you
switchin exist or you switch like a
policy division method I just want to
show this to smooth the greedy roux is
good it's not coincidence actually you
can't prove a band ok so this is a here
I'm just talk about polynomial time
algorithms computation time a gram total
number under whatever and they say is a
polynomial MN if you also depend on the
beach and data then you become
polynomial if only treatment on MN is
become strong polynomial time ok so I
know this is all
for a know if this is a kind of a
complexity classification still popular
in computer science or not but but still
very very good the theoretical question
even for today you may Argus all today
emmalin just get into big even
polynomial is not good but in all London
I have knows know what to say or do
whatever but in practice people always
do dimension retouching and do some
approximation sampling on our so reduce
the dimension so but anyway so give it a
proper MN pan you're finding a
polynomial strongly polynomial time out
to solve this under nine programs okay
the standard approved for polynomial
time our group when the gabba potenza
objective value current a policy in this
case you can prove every policy it's
like a basic feasible solution for the
linear programming problems ok 2 to the
minus L then current force must be
optimal but this kind of a gap argument
is it can be used to prove strong point
of polynomial time but not be adequate
to prove strongly polynomial ok because
the admin there has to be more comfort
or e
yeah there was a man amended active
result i already mentioned smoothly in
dec zoo action is not also 2010 family
said exponential number iteration even
for august county the fight on Horizonte
p ok free man Hansen civic and also give
mdp example show random people the root
is exponentially many step as well
friedman also so cause other rule needs
explain too many steps so all those are
different the rules it's basically say
and for somehow and steel simplex is
still overwhelmingly negative okay
that's what I started this very well so
many efforts has been fed so many many
County example are some extreme cases
but here I'm just say go back to
original discounted fun infrared horizon
and DP okay so what's this and turn out
okay here's the theorems okay the casket
simplex mess thanks captivity rule and
it's a Polish Ambassador starting from
any policy terminated in n times n minus
m1 minus K divided by one minus gamma
log M square 1 minus couple iterations
that's it and there was no big constant
of only I read still remember what's
gamma gamma is the discount so you say
you for next year's rally is point a 999
gamma is 49
so what this tells you this tells you
actually if gamma is fixed treated them
as a constant which is normally with you
even other implications and this is
actually quadratic time that's pretty
much people mourn as observed in
practice quadratic number four simplex
method steps okay well assume after and
the handsome deterrents awake I cm12
publish it okay they said policy region
Manson actually terminates in an over-
common log and small steps the proof is
pretty much follow the regional proof in
terms of overall structure but as a very
intelligent get more detailed analysis
so what this means that's policy
iteration action in linear time if gamma
is fixed which again is what people the
conjecture in practice
again what is the M number of stage and
total number of action
so this is a but but as a Bobby said you
need more computational time to compute
a cost to go values this is dead here
you only update the only in quadratic
attack ok what's the high-level idea of
the proof yes the dancing rule was the
greedy room yes that's the greedy room
yeah the most an active reduce the cost
yeah
so you basically as I said what's the
optimal policy or democracy is a winning
card for each state so there was some
non winning card you have a non optimal
action optoma actions so they basically
create a long optimal which is what is
the ARB game action so auction would not
be included in the final optimal policy
we say that oxygen will never enter the
policy again because you constantly
generate the new policies to try a
policy intermediate policy but that
action is somehow eliminated I don't
know which one you minute but are now
there was one eliminated okay and also
is there okay it's a fixed so so you
will know we're having a most a certain
polynomial number iterations more
precisely after em over 1 minus Karma's
of these iterations a new lump Obama
Allah optimum action will be intimidated
from appearance any future basis or mdp
language in the future policies ok so
the event the contributor another now
optimal state so you only have this many
earth to be eliminated so and these
times knees and that's it that's not
okay what to make poverty is actually
you only need the one over by McCarver
iterations in policy division method
long and long performer or now optimal
action will be implicitly so that's the
high-level proof so it's very
competitive very elementary as well
okay now what happened to 10 based
two-person zero-sum game okay as I said
the saturdays does not this is the
interesting problems from computer
science point of view even up to day
which you don't know whether this
problem for mdp because the special
subclass of linear programming the
compass of the important organ time but
for these problems we still don't know
whether its foreign owners over or not
if even you can't the discounters
variables or whatever okay it does not
emit a convex programming like a linear
programming way we mentioned okay still
unknown okay however in the same a
central papers oh there was a there was
a method to solve this game problems is
called a strategy to reach method it's
like a stock bug game so I want to
minimize whenever I played assume my
adversary follow the exactly to maximize
the scenes so it's like it's like it's
like I'm neither i'm changing my cards
my photo always respond in the best
interest okay it turned out you can
similar transfer this policy Reese
ambassador to this strategy to reach
method again this is the band how how
much you reach the optimal strategy on
which is optimal for you okay so if you
gamma is fixed and then this becomes
linear time are groups so this actually
is the first polynomial time algorithms
and just kind of fact it's fixed
it is still unknown if it can be solved
in polynomial time and then use but here
you have to assume gamma is fixed okay
yes so you forgot it's but this is the
one yeah this is this is a tool for
gamma fixed or not fixed but a you
wanted to make is this a statement is
this twenty Polidori you have to assume
gamma is fixed but that's what it is
yeah yes before you see the like lower
bounds results of a MBP do they apply
you also wear when gum is not fixed yes
miss gamma is not fixed well yes that's
right that's right that's right like
offending whatever he already have
examples so at this counter played a big
role here in terms of competition you
whenever yeah there was a different way
yeah basically they can construct the
worst example so now but but overall
they're still not involve any time
you're right yeah so this is a okay so
follow this kind of a result and I saw a
couple increase result is called the
robust MTV with discount since we talked
about the decision maker and uncertainty
a very popular model is called the
robust Merriman um dia application state
transition to tribution may be uncertain
while nami advance so so many many
applications even today's ok so the
robust IPO what is assumed that when a
decision make place actions and words
afraid will always choose or what's the
decision to maximize the expected to go
gossip okay so this is the typical min
max then so this is a voter estate it's
like the MDP game okay they always
wanted to maximize so you just create
the adversary state after each actions
he can choose some distributions
his pocket and then whenever that is
very sugar he called katha cloak us to
go values they choose the maximum
distributive value maximize not the
actions the gift of you wanna ok so you
somehow and this robusta MDB is actually
a special case of this stochastic a team
so it's very easy sin of course depend
on how many distributions you can choose
and this is the total number of actions
and the number of state becomes M plus M
so this is number two reasons so this is
a so-called robotic mdp so you basically
your bass camp TB can be represent as
the stem based of stochastic again
I'm doing okay okay so this can be over
there okay okay I think you guys asked a
very good washing all these still depend
on the gum so yeah the lighting is
eternity for not anything else
distribution how mass it is in the heart
diseases but it's a pound is still
dependent on gamma okay as they were
also said I'm DP actually actually even
even even even wear some gum is very
very small but somehow practically still
works very well whatever okay but we do
have some bad examples so the cracks the
question what we do is we try to tackle
this code this deterministic mdp okay we
try to see in general cannot get rid of
a gamma dependence on gamma but maybe
for certain subclass problems and then
we can get rid of gamma okay so one
particular problem is we are shown the
probabilities reversion contain exact 11
and the zero everywhere else so that's
like whenever you take action for sure
you know which state you're going to end
up okay not clear ok so that's called
the deterministic mdp but this program
actually is try to find a generalized
psycho flow problems is the theorems
okay and we somehow succeeded actually
get rid of dependence on gamma is
regardless what gamma how close to white
is you know how big it is depends mdp ok
Khamenei's very bad about them and to
the power 3 and square looks where Emma
iterations yes
true love really waiting only for greedy
okay this is a assume other etching have
the same discount factors if the
discount factor is different as I said
before and that's more like even high or
whatever but never sneeze I do have a
constant over there is somehow eight
times something whenever it's not like
one meeting with something wherever so
do have a bigger all over thee because
there was some overhead costs but it's
the constant never see
so here's the yeah 42 minutes crime TV
simplex method in its strong opponent
even for any gamma okay even gamma I'll
be very close to one so this is a so
somehow put some and positive news voice
okay and also Hanson and civic they they
can reduce one factor M from this bound
subsequently been more careful analysis
the Panda is very bad but the probe is
interesting so maybe as I said and all
this proof has to be very competitive
you cannot just like simple things okay
yeah freedom you turn out each policy
come to resend as a graph as I said each
policy is to choose one action from each
state right so it could be like this
then forming a psycho or could be every
is a psycho level okay so you want a
finding of one with all different the
discount you wanna find in such a
structure with this structure have a
minimum discounted a cost that's what it
is okay so if you okay then there was a
to type of things structures on this
graph some state you have action is
under owe me energy now some stage you
have these under psychos okay so we
basically say you have a path edgy you
may have a psycho edgy in any policies
okay and also so expect you the
frequency I'm talking about a primer
where the frequency flow values once you
have this cycle you psycho you've lied
horizons Monster Energy you only pass
these ones and then enter over there
so's also flow values are those energies
are very small but at a cycle very very
big because the special and discount so
you have this to type of 4p was whether
the edge you choose in and the new
policy is under cycle on the edges okay
so this is a proof i'm talking about a
uniform discount the newly chosen
actually is on a part on a cycle okay
then you every is this number of
consecutive appearances there must be at
least one step that is a cycle once your
only changes the path the only small
improvement in the simplex method okay
but once you have a p-word the newly
chosen edges on cycle you make a big
improvement or whatever so the questions
we have two bound it so in some sense
there was two layers you know so you
foster people what you you wait until
your big givers and then you have to
perform not smoke keyboard but you can
bury it okay and this a.m cycle given
steps it's done optimax you whatever be
chosen again so it's like one like what
I proved it before everybody's
one-dayers remember but here you have
two layers okay so you're you're pretty
mud here from non-uniform this kind of
case they actually have a different
level soon ever so each of then you just
formulate and try proof for example the
proof is much much more evolved for this
non-uniform cycle but a uniform
basically these times these give your
total number of steps so very again very
elementary very competitive okay more
result and this result was tented to
general 90 general key cassava and a
Missoula okay so they basically say and
all these analyses applicable to non
degenerate an inner programming
algorithms okay 90g no means every basic
variable has a positive values
ok so my 1 1 over 1 minus gamma is like
10 verse most apposite evil values not
space cadet so that proof is very simple
ok but however you forums the general is
degenerate I don't know whether there
was a polynomial algorithm to to get out
of cycle whatever simplex Macedonia even
even the yeah so this is a I'm still
don't know okay the few examples yeah
non degenerate no I mean the just
approximate actually what's the case for
simplex method is 90 generator it's not
good you yeah it's just a very is just
like gamma very closely yes actually
many was it's not about a generator or
not and also create a renewed exciting
research and simplex method and also
linear programming so cup of paper very
recently and foreign suvari you know and
also people here and also did some nice
work try to improve simplex method and
these complex
so in some sense simplex felt the
research is still very alive looks like
Steve's so I'm going to make I only have
a two page in turn left make some
remarks to Palmers a simplex masters
very sensitive to the Peabody room looks
like yeah so of course and people still
looking for whether there is a good
people in ruined can handle all the
cases so we still don't know okay but an
insta for mdp we saw with the difference
between smooth in tax law and greedy
room yeah so talk about as I said policy
Tracy very decentralized okay it seems
works under this kind of a mark of
poverty okay and it's just people pastor
response to some message and I know it's
also pepper very popular now mention any
of this message passing arguments on the
staff yeah it's just everybody
decentralized and for your own interest
and take the best action yourself so
that's what a policy okay a greedy
austerity set a watchman since there was
discount okay so that's seems natural
and because this is kinda discount of
future value so greedy should be a good
rule Marty updates people's work better
than single update sneaker is approvable
case we proved people the prove the
iteration is better than simplex on the
overall a number of steps okay so that
seems works okay so also this kind of a
method because so decentralized so you
can easily combined with dynamic
sampling to deal with large number of
actions into state okay so people
retinal solve some problems yeah if you
use these kind of loose ends with not if
number of actions too many of course
it's still not good so what people
usually do is the sample some actions
then just just prove some state okay so
this is a song okay okay yeah I saw cut
for walks and also solve online MTP is
like mdp for each state the action is
revealed sequentially okay so it's like
an LP problems you only have a few
Colin's but you have many many corners
to add into this primer MVP forms okay
so the questions know if on Caillou
dynamically updating your policies until
actually get a good complexity bank and
even and it's very very big level okay
this sink a ship ran did some nice work
on how cojelo nonlinear programming monk
Eliza one linear programming the matrix
reveal the from neff to write a
sequential you but at each time you have
to make a decision whatever okay so this
would be a good online okay then policy
revision just update an update I believe
that cost to go value must have some
concentration so you can prove some nice
view you don't need too many samples are
not some permutation or some generation
okay is simple acts 20 point of a
deterministic MTP cane we proved the
simplex method it is 20 polynomial for
deterministic and TP process which means
only have one group to minimize what
about a four game if you can prove that
that would be actually I believe that's
a good big step because again for
complexity for game is virtually unknown
many many aspects especially when gamma
is also variables his policy regime s 24
lawyer for the deterministic ntp
approved yum post and I approved and the
symbol X it is 20 polynomial for general
deterministic MTP means gamma can be up
very close to 14 however we're not able
to prove for policy division is it okay
if you know works and that very high
complexity barnacle should it become
down because as I said for discounted
NDP you monkeys count is fixed and
policy is a linear time and simply as
quadratic attack so it's very intriguing
and we don't know what we do okay so it
looks like everything I works for some
plaque should we move to vote to policy
but that's the case and not able to do
it assertive you was actually for MTP
game again and we still don't know even
then the game can be solved in detail
okay so this is a set and it's very
tough problems but many many real pop-
ask NDP actually can't be formulated
it's a strong put it out before mdp I
want to be able to for deterministic
okay for Nigeria we have to assume gamma
is fixed so this is since whenever come
is fixed everything is nice extremely
lies not only polynomial strongly
polynomial but however for this kind of
varies we don't know much so this is
like a very very troubling horrible okay
of course the big peaches is still
strongly polynomial time for FP as i
said before and the people nowadays may
not be interested in this as a
computational problems but however it is
a very very intriguing and I sing steel
since this is the theory of computation
sigh machines to do so i hope some
people here can answer that question
thank you very much yes what's known
about lower bound on the number of
iterations for Policy iteration for
example do we know any examples of MVPs
that require more than 3 n iterations
apology duration [ __ ] father's coming
back yeah for and it is kind of factor
people actually have a perp and Jay can
construct example I actually have a
Sabah exponential know about so it yeah
222 yeah some n over epsilon was
something yeah or yeah no absolute to
some power or something I yeah yes it's
topic as well it actually is in the
explain so in general as i said if this
country is not a fixed we do have
examples to show policy and simplex both
need the sub explanation i believe the
people data are also construct an
example not only sub explanation but
also explain so for this count is the
simplex cannot be work and policy cannot
work
you have two new have some new
algorithms may be may be combined with
some unity pro in the algorithms will
never leave you can create some comfort
at oranjee pornography do this that's
what the alice madre did something for
maximum flow looks like a very
intelligent and combined some
comparisons for for uniform maximum flow
you ready
let's thanks okay thank you